yeah i think that the bay is like
we were just talking a little bit about
this but i think the bay is its own
it's it's very there's the only place
that i can kind of like
on a very much smaller scale
is i moved to tampa and i went to when i
did radio in tampa for a few years
and when i went to the club there i
heard some [ __ ] called juke music
and it's only in tampa where that [ __ ]
get played
nowhere else it's like a hundred trying
to say it's like a go-go thing it's like
105 bpms with bells in it it's like it's
like
it's some [ __ ] it's it's called tampa
juke music and i was like
what what the [ __ ] is this yeah and i
feel like in the bay
it's the biggest example of that as far
as like
except for you know i i the bay has
influenced everybody
a lot i mean no like i feel like the
beta does not get there just do and i
say this all the time i think the bay
has so much influence on hip-hop thanks
and they don't get there not just
hip-hop
[ __ ] fashion technology check now of
course that's actually of course
you know what i mean like it's a lot
more we
but i feel like it's just an island and
it's like
okay like you could go to the bay and
they'll be like
there'll be like records that go up that
aren't even necessarily bay records
that are just so big that you'll be like
yo this song was like
this was a big record like what and you
won't even really know like that
yeah like you won't even really know the
song like that unless you come to the
bay
and you see the effect of it so you
driving through the bay you hearing it
on the radio you seeing people in the
car play
you big you're a big dj so i'm sure
you've had a lot of
dj gigs up there where you're spinning
in the clubs and you
hearing the people coming to you telling
you to play records that you might not
even have like what the hell is this
no that happened to me one time and then
i i just i had to be like okay
i had to hit a homie and be like yo i
just need that i just need the folder of
like the
odd records that i should just have on
deck
for if i'm ever do and it was like just
gotta have crazy [ __ ]
like trunk boys cupcake no filling yeah
[ __ ] that you just would never expect
like
i want to say like baby boy like just
some like random [ __ ] that like you're
like yo i didn't know this song was a
thing like i knew about the song but i
didn't know anywhere else
gave a [ __ ] about it but now i do think
that it's like you know obviously with
the rich history of the bay it's dope
that
there is you know for what you do there
is
a dope side of the bay there's you know
back in the 90s there was hyrule
and souls of mischief and all that but i
think that like
you're bringing a lot of people
associate mozzie with the base from
sacramento thanks
uh shout out to the fella fella too
that's about that man shout out mazzy
shout out to sacramento too
but i feel like you're in a dope
position where you're um
you can make music that that
everybody in hip-hop respects and you
also happen to be from the bay
as opposed to like because i think a lot
of times with bay area artists we
associate them with being from the bay
first
and unfortunately there's some sort of
preconceived
stigma that comes with that that you
might have already made up your mind
about that artist even though you
you know that's not fair that's not okay
but i mean it's it's it's
it is what it is it's a life you know i
mean like we look at things and we judge
it sometimes
like 24 karat golden's got the number
one song in the country and i had no
idea
recently you wouldn't know he was from
the bay but it's like he's doing a
different type of thing
you know i mean most people like you
said you know they from the baby because
you could hear it in the music
you can hear it in the sound you can
hear it and how they represent
themselves
certain things they may post on
instagram or where they may be
but there's a another level we could
take things too
that's a uh g-eazy level k lonnie level
and now
24k level so where we could take things
to another level to where the world
could identify with us and rock with us
and we could speak for debate and be a
platform for other artists in the bay
they want to take it to that same level